people aren't starting they're just not
making they're thinking they're
pondering they're strategizing they're
debating a lot of people look at
finished products they look at LeBron
today they look at Kobe today they look
at Beyonce today you know the difference
between understanding who you are versus
who you wish you were I mean if you want
to be respected and really known show
the [__] up enough listening start doing
[__] don't be scared and if you're
scared find somebody who's not scared
make them your partner like it's action
it's going it's doing and if you're
passionate about something in your world
you can make a big difference you've got
to pump out content but here's where
people that pump out content make a
mistake they care about the camera and
the lighting and all that other horse
crap